[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'altra notte
Mia moglie mi ha abbracciato eravamo a
letto era commossa
mi stava raccontando di quel bambino che
è stato abbandonato alla Mangiagalli di
Milano qualche giorno fa
Allora io mi sono girato e l'ho
abbracciata
cercavo le parole
e non le ho trovate Eppure avrei dovuto
trovarle perché io sono stato
abbandonato da mia madre
avevo 13 anni era il 1973
torno a casa un pomeriggio e in cucina
sul tavolo di formica rossa di una
cucina stile anni 60 trova una bottiglia
di vetro in mille lire che sarebbero
diventate la cena a base di caffè latte
per me e i miei fratelli e un
bigliettino con delle scarne parole ma
molto pesanti praticamente
scaricava la responsabilità addosso
dell'educazione dei miei fratelli
io non posso vivere in quell'inferno lei
diceva
proprio quelle parole
sei anni dopo nel 1979 la rincontro per
la prima volta dopo l'abbandono
era
una domenica di primavera assolata
un giorno che non dimenticherò mai Io ho
cercato di essere il più in ordine
possibile
il più pulito il più Pettinato
passa una giornata bellissima la
guardavo era più bella di come me la
ricordavo era più bella di quelle
fotografie che tenevo sotto il cuscino
L'unica cosa che la vedevo più piccola
Senza rendermi conto che io ero
cresciuto
quando la prego di tornare a casa
lei mi dice io in quell'inferno non ci
torno e se n'è andata
noi in quell'inferno ci vivevamo
dovevamo fare le cose più semplici
cucinare e poi rassettare lavare i panni
e poi stenderli dovevamo vivere
perché mio padre pensava solo a lavorare
e ad annegare il suo dolore dentro i
bottiglioni di vino dove
arrivava il fondo di questo verde
smeraldo
per cercare una soluzione
e invece trovava solo Odio il rancore
per quella abbandono che riversava su di
noi
i miei fratelli erano più piccoli di me
Io avevo 13 anni Marco ne aveva 11 E i
gemellini Sandro e Loredana ne avevano
otto
però papà non era cattivo assolutamente
non c'è mai picchiato però non ci ha mai
dato neppure una carezza e neppure un
sorriso lui aveva delle regole delle
regole ben precise a me diceva quando
fai una cosa Falla al massimo delle tue
possibilità sempre bene Qualunque cosa
essa sia poi ha cominciato a dirmi stai
diventando grande attento alle ragazze
devi avere rispetto Guarda che se poi le
metti incinta
Ero terrorizzato
il primo bacio lo dà no me lo hanno dato
che avevo già 18 anni
e allora ha cominciato subito a lavorare
già 13 anni ho cominciato con
il lavando i piatti poi in un'impresa di
pulizia andavo a pulire le scuole gli
uffici Poi ho fatto carrozziere il
battilama il verniciatore poi ho fatto
il venditore di acqua minerale il
venditore di marmi e granito ho lavorato
in una fabbrica sono fatto tutto quello
che potevo fare
e tutti questi mestieri mi sono serviti
per arrivare a pensare che un giorno
tutti questi mestieri mi sarebbero stati
utili per l'occasione perché tutti nella
vita abbiamo un'occasione Io non credo
nella fortuna per niente credo
che c'è il momento in cui il talento
incontra l'occasione e noi tutti abbiamo
un talento di quanti
un pomeriggio esco dalla vasca da bagno
e sono davanti questo specchio bagnato
fradicio e grido mamma mi prendi
l'asciugamano
ma non è venuto nessuno perché mia madre
non c'era se ne era andata via Allora
guardandomi dritto negli occhi ho capito
che io dovevo arrangiarmi da solo che
dovevo dare retta a me stesso
perché noi tutti quando ci guardiamo
allo specchio la verità la sappiamo
possiamo mentire con chiunque ma noi la
sappiamo io questa cosa qui la chiamo
vocina
è la mia vocina
mi chiede di fare delle cose che spesso
Sono esattamente il contrario di quello
che mi dice il mondo che mi sta intorno
È difficile dargli retta
nel
mio padre muore di cancro e secondo me
anche di quel mal di vivere che gli si
era appiccicato addosso quando mamma se
n'è andata
aveva 51 anni è morto molto molto
giovane
e io dopo il funerale torno in quella
cucina
sul tavolo di formica Rossa questa volta
c'è il suo bottiglione di vino e lo bevo
per capire che cosa aveva quel vino più
di me più di noi più della nostra vita
Poi apro un cassetto dove lui
accumulava le sue cianfrusaglie
e trovo un giornale
che racconta di quel 1982 io avevo 22
anni dove avevo vinto il talentiere
una fotografia ne ritraeva con Teddy
Reno Rita Pavone e la mia band avevo
vinto
e lui andava in giro con questo giornale
era orgoglioso di me ma non lo aveva mai
detto a me
non me l'aveva mai detto
a quel punto Grazie
a quel punto decido di andare via dalla
Liguria quella terra mi aveva fatto solo
male e per i 6 anni successivi incontro
nuove persone
nuove dialetti faccio nuovi lavori mi
sposo per la prima volta
e trovo una famiglia
Trova un equilibrio
passa il tempo
e quella vocina
si rifà viva mi diceva Scusa ma non
raccontiamo più niente non facciamo
niente Io non gli davo retta perché
stavo bene Avevo trovato un equilibrio
avevo trovato una famiglia e quindi
continuava a vendere i marmi e i graniti
dell'azienda di mio suocero
Poi un giorno un mio amico viene a casa
e mi porta un oggetto magico una
telecamera per comuni mortali io ci
metto l'occhio dentro il mirino e perdo
completamente la testa
scopro un mondo tutto tutto nuovo tutto
da scoprire che mi appassiona e comincio
a studiare tutto ciò che è quello che
vive intorno al mondo della ripresa
dell'immagine mia moglie pensa che io
sia pazzo mi lascia e io lascio la
famiglia quella nuova famiglia che avevo
trovato e me ne torno in Liguria e lì
Ricomincia da capo lavori saltuari
Cerco di studiare continuamente
compatibilmente con la sopravvivenza Che
cosa dovevo fare lavoro con due studi
uno era con Renzo Melis a Genova e Renzo
faceva servizi per il telegiornale e un
altro in Toscana con Giacomo De Simone
il re dei videoclip
io all'interno di quegli studi veniva
chiamato il vecchio avevo 32 anni e gli
operatori gli avevano 19 io ero il
vecchio
facevo una vita veramente difficile
stenti perché guadagnavo 250.000 lire al
mese ed e spendevo 450 mila il primo
giorno per l'affitto Quindi stavo sotto
della metà ancora prima di cominciare
in quel periodo
montavo caminetti per un'azienda di
Perugia
il titolare un giorno mi chiama e mi
dice Duccio Senti se tu la smetti di
saltare i giorni di lavoro per andare a
fare il videomaker e viene a lavorare
per me Io ti assumo e ti metto in regola
e ti do uno stipendio
io ero veramente sfinito stanco
è quella cosa mi ha cominciato a girare
nella testa Quasi quasi non l'ascolto
più la mia vocina quali racconti
finalmente ti puoi risistemare
torno a casa con questo pensiero nella
testa
taglio il piombi della del contatore
elettrico perché erano passati i signori
della energia elettrica avevano piombato
perché non avevo pagato la corrente ma
il telefono lo pagavo sempre
torno a casa mi faccio due uova al volo
e ci avevo questa voce che mi diceva
stipendio fisso
squilla il telefono
rispondo
dall'altro capo mi risponde un signore
che dice buonasera Sono Andrea Papalia
dalla Sony Music Entertainment Cercavo
il regista Duccio Forzano l'ho mandato a
quel paese e ho sbattuto giù il telefono
regista a me non me l'aveva mai detto
nessuno
e se era vero e se questo cercava
veramente me allora non è che c'era rpt
ultima chiamata non c'era niente C'è un
telefono grigio con una rotella
Andrea pepalia richiama non mi sbatte il
telefono in faccia Io sto cercando il
regista Duccio Forzano
e io a quel punto faccio finta di niente
di come dica devo fare un videoclip
Perché Claudio Baglioni
e volevo sapere se lei è disponibile
devo montare qualche caminetto ma il
tempo lo trovo
e poi non abbiamo molti soldi e a me
rovina dire che non c'ha molti soldi
questo
dico Guardi signora Andrea mi dica
Quanti soldi ha
17 milioni di lire ma io per 17 milioni
vi faccio ben uno non vi faccio un
videoclip
adesso voi vi domanderete come possibile
che Claudio Baglioni va a cercare un
anonimo montatore di caminetti in
Liguria
io per Giacomo di Simone quel signore
Toscano il re dei videoclip Avevo girato
avevo lavorato in un set dove avevamo
girato un video di e con Paola Massari
Paola Massari moglie prima moglie di
Claudio Baglioni quando Claudio cercava
il regista per il suo nuovo videoclip
Paola gli ha detto guarda che c'è questo
ragazzetto di Genova che si dà molto da
fare a grande passione io ti suggerisco
di prendere lui E lui disse andatevi a
prendere Duccio Forzano ed Eccoli che
Andrea è arrivato
io lì ho capito nel 1995 avevo 35 anni
che tutti gli ostacoli che avevo
affrontato fino a quel momento erano il
motore per arrivare in quel preciso
istante e a 35 anni ho girato il mio
primo videoclip Bolero per Claudio
Baglioni E subito dopo
sarebbero arrivati Palasport e subito
dopo sarebbe arrivata la televisione ma
questa è un'altra storia
[Applauso]
per la musica
penso della
appena accelerati sono arrivato a uno
attenzione per la grafica
[Applauso]
i secondi attenzione
vai con la grafica musica
Uno dentro
Tre dentro sei dentro quattro dentro due
dentro
uno dentro tre dentro sei dentro quattro
dentro due dentro nove centro
una brilla Rossa
destra 4
Grazie